so this is a song about yeah the hands  and the hit and the hot and what what we  can be  [Music]  with my hand I'll build a spaceship in  case we run out of room like a wizard  who helps everybody's dreams come true  with my hands I only wanted to good  wouldn't you do that if you only could  with my head I'll write a song about  saving the world every River every robot  every boy every girl singing wisdom is  the one missing thing what I feel when I  [Music]  when I close my eyes  [Music]  No  [Music]  whoo I will my heart I'll turn your  sadness into unicorns and rainbows with  more colors and roses with performance  with our hearts we travel so far  together we start wet  [Music]  I know  [Music]  who  [Music]  with our hearts we can travel too far  together we came from the stars  where the house we travel survived  together we can even start  [Music]  ah  such a good owner didn't philosophy book  right